hey what's up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to episode 15 of network chat
programming so today we're going to talk
more about the server and specifically
getting started with some actual server
guards so last time we took a look of
course at these command-line arguments
and that really gave us a way to
actually set the port number here
dynamically in a way right because we're
actually getting input from the user
without a GUI but more or less we're
starting a we're starting a server based
on the user's specifications at this
point which is the port number so now
that we've done this right we've made a
little thing here we can actually get
rid of I'm not sure why we don't think
we need this this global variable as
such yeah probably gonna say no yeah
okay we'll get rid of this so this all
particles port we don't need that and we
don't need this private import okay
we're just we're just passing it from
the constructor and we're actually going
to be passing it into our server which
happens here okay so how do we actually
start the server well glad you asked is
actually really simple we've got this
constructor here what we're gonna do is
we're gonna actually run new server okay
now I lied just then I deleted something
I probably shouldn't have and I just
realized why we decided to divide the
server that we did we actually decided
to divide the the actual logic behind
the server and add the actual server
stuff so in other words the back-end I
guess you'd call it the actual sending
or saving and dealing with packets to be
in its own class and then the interface
to be another one now we should probably
use the port here and the reason we
should use it is because um you know the
user might want to request for example
what port number were currently and we
sort of want to give the user the user
some level of interactivity with the
service in other words we might get we
might let the user for example run a
command like you know - port or
something and then hit enter and I'll
actually print the port number that I
was running on just in case the user
forgot of course I could just scroll
through the history and see how they
started it but if it's been several days
maybe a problem so we'll just put that
in there as a cool little thing and
because of that we'll also make an
actual object here called server server
right and we'll set server equal to new
server so I'm not just
a server actually assigning it to a
variable so that we can then call
methods and get information from it
awesome so what we've got now is a
server object so if we go back into
server to Java we've got a blank server
so let's start okay so the first thing
we're pretty much going to do here is
make I guess the the server side the
server side of the client version so if
we go back to client here just for
reference
we've course created a Datagram socket
with with a with the port and we did all
this cool stuff but over here in in
server ok we're gonna do like literally
pretty much the same thing
okay so we'll make we'll make another
private data gram socket socket and
we'll make a socket equal to new diagram
socket where the port number okay now
this is literally the same as a client
and you might be like what the hell's
the difference and well there really is
not you know a difference whoops there's
really not that much of a difference
when you're handling UDP stuff there's
no difference there is of course when
you don't taste it pay and the reason
there is when you're doing tasty payment
again is this again but just lightly the
reason there is a difference when you're
doing TCP is because there's stuff like
authentication and and delivery and like
sure Asian I guess going on where I'm
mmm that's probably not a word a
serration assurance of the delivery I
guess but you know with TCP you've got
stuff like protocols that actually make
sure packets do get there and get resent
if they don't and that's why there is
something that the server does extra but
with UDP remember you're just sending a
packet to another host yeah now the
reason we've called this the server is
because this will be like the other the
okay I guess the center point if you
picture like a hub and spoke on a
topology which is where you've got a
center and then everything else is
connected like the spokes on a bicycle
wheel for example you've got the the
middle the axle and then you've got all
the spokes going out this is kind of a
spark sorry this kind of our axle
all right this server this is kind of
like the center point
and all the clients connect to this one
server and of course as of such the
server is not just you know required to
receive all these packets of data and
just do something with them it's
required to actually manage all the
clients and nor from which packet it
comes from and it's quite a complicated
process but luckily luckily you have
made it explain it to you okay so to do
this right to manage all this stuff
there's a lot there's a lot of stuff
going on with server especially with
threading okay so we'll make a thread
right now here called a probably just a
run thread yeah and this will just run
the server so kind of like we did in
game programming will implement will
implement runnable here which which just
gives the server its own thread so it's
not running on the default javathread it
gives us a bit more control here and we
of course get this awesome run method as
a result which will run when we actually
start so what we'll do here is we'll set
run equal to new thread we'll call it
the well first of all this right because
it we're referring to this class and
since it is implementing article and
that will cause this run method to run
but we'll call it let's call it server
right because just this is just the
server thread okay not a receiving not
sending just be plain server thread and
over here in run this is where all the
stuff is gonna happen so first of all we
should probably check if a server is
running or not so I can't I'll make a
boolean here called running it set it
equal to false and when we do run we'll
set running it's true okay and we'll
have a while loop in here like we do all
the time and this is the other thing
right this server should really have a
bit of a while loop going on and the
reason is is constantly constantly
listening for packets now clients are as
well but this is doing him something a
bit extra it's actually having to manage
separate packets and assign them to the
right client so it does get it does get
quite challenging at times but you know
we'll work it up I'm sure we will
okay so I like to let me um just think
of a nice method name here so I like to
make a method that's separate from the
wrong method which essentially just
manages I guess the clients all more or
less kind of receives the daughter from
the clients I'm just thinking here oh no
ok so we'll make him manage clients ok
and we'll also make a receive method
those two methods okay now so the manage
client will be a void manage clients I
can and that'll be responsible and
that'll have its own thread by the way
that'll be responsible for um that'll be
responsible for managing the clients so
not receiving not you know per say
receiving data but yes it was not gonna
receive data but what it will do guess
what the receive is for what manage
clients will be doing is essentially
sending out a start sending out things
like pings every now and then so maybe
like let's just say once every five
seconds or something once every two
seconds whatever it'll send out like a
you know like a like a ping and then it
will see if the client actually replies
and if the client doesn't then we can
assume that you know we'll send a few
more pings just in case it's a lost
packet or something but after a while we
can assume that the user is pretty much
timed out or the user has you know
improperly closed their application
because when a client closes their
little chat window we want to actually
set it send a disconnect packet to the
server just to make sure that we
actually remove that client from the
from the from the list of clients
basically but sometimes people will just
end process or just I don't know
unplug their computer from the
PowerPoint and kill it that way right if
it's on a laptop with a battery or
whatever just hold power button shut it
off that way and if you do that
obviously you know the computer has no
chance to send that packet the
application has no chances and that
could buy a packet and that's why we of
course need to send checks so the manage
clients will basically manage the
clients I don't provide any comment that
okay it will manage the clients it'll
make sure the best still there it'll
make sure that it disconnects them if
they're not still there and some of that
now receive okay receive will do
something totally different receive will
actually receive any kind of data that
it gets and it's actually very very
vital how we handle
this receive process okay
now the reason it's vital is because you
know we're not just receiving a packet
from one client we could be receiving
packets every millisecond pretty much
okay we're receiving a ton of Packers we
might have 50 clients here we might have
stuff like disconnecting and
reconnecting connecting sending messages
to each other sending messages to a
specific client we will have all mayhem
going on here so the receive has to be
very very vigilant okay so what I'll do
is over here in in a private thread run
I'll actually make two more threads
again oh I'll make one called I don't
think what do we need one for we do need
one for manage clients okay I'll make a
managed one I'll make a send one and
I'll make a receive one so right now
we've got four threads so manage clients
when we first start manage clients we
will hit manage equals new thread
they're not this new thread again we'll
call it manage okay and that will of
course be an honor
I'm sorry not much time hang on a minute
yes it will be okay so we'll make a um
make a new thread here that is indeed an
hour on this type here will make public
water on I'll talk a bit about this
anonymous stuff in a minute now but
public word run and then at the end wolf
start this manage don't start okay cool
so now that we've got this make sure you
close out with a semicolon now only
about this this this anonymous stuff
basically just means that instead of us
having to make a class and implement
runnable separately we can just do it in
here okay we've implemented this run
method inside this method instead of
having to make a new class specifically
for that just basically um cooled down
the code here instead of having to type
heaps and heaps of lines occured we've
made it a lot easier for ourselves and a
lot cleaner it might be in the list okay
so we this is good okay this is the the
manage thread and in the manage thread
yeah in the manage thread what we'll
have is a while loop
now while true probably isn't the best
practice
what I will have is a while running loop
this ensures that if running for some
reason is set equal to false will
actually make all these threads stop
okay because this will eventually equal
false and that means we get to the end
of this wire loop which of course gets
out of this run method entirely okay and
this is where all of our managing
happens okay so more or less oops
managing awesome so now that we've got
that we should focus on the receive
method so the receive method will be let
me just might just make a bunch of
spaces here so you guys will see this in
the center of your screen rather than at
the bottom so we'll make the receive
whoops will make the receive thread
equal to a new thread it'll call this
one receive and whoops and we'll make it
again an anonymous implementation here
so and we'll start receive okay and of
course we'll have a while running loop
as well so these are virtually identical
okay but of course the code inside and
will be different now why am i splitting
this into two different methods you
could argue and the reason I'm splitting
into two different methods of Huffman
obviously the point of having two
different threads for it is because you
know essentially manage clients is doing
one job receiver to me and on the job
it's a very small idea to separate your
code like that because if we have an
error that spawns in the receive part
and we can say there's nothing to do
with managing lines is just to do with
receiving with donna receiving the
actual data okay and vice versa so a
good idea okay so this ron remember this
is no kind of loop this run runs once so
what happens is it says running it's
true it starts this thread essentially
by calling this method such as this
thread per calling this method method
and then that's it it's gone okay that
is the only purpose pretty much of this
run a thread which is why I called it
that okay it's pretty much over its life
is just to to run the server to start it
okay cool so that's pretty much it okay
that's gonna wrap up this episode but in
the next I got rid of run of course
somehow but of course in the next
episode we will talk about either Matt
message and managing we're saving all
sending now sending I'm not gonna cover
sending just yet okay
we'll talk about managing and risk we'll
talk about receiving that song because
receiving has to happen before managing
because managing relies on receiving
right we receive data and we manage it
this is like a maintenance method
okay so we'll talk about receiving next
time yeah so if you guys did enjoy this
episode without my shepherd I mean
please the like button 200 likes one
video per day 300 likes two videos per
day and I will see you guys next time
good bye
you